[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Yeah, welcome to
today's Talks at Google event.
We're here to
welcome Neil Gibson.
He's founder and editor-in-chief
of the British comic book
publisher TPub.
He writes several
of their titles,
including but not limited
to the "Twisted Dark"
series and several
other series with T.
He speaks to
businesses and students
about how they can use comic
books to their advantage.
And today he's here
to talk about how
comics can help you improve
your memory and your career.
So please welcome Neil Gibson.
[APPLAUSE]
NEIL GIBSON: Can I ask
a quick show of hands--
who here actually reads comics?
Almost everyone.
Great.
Not you, kind of.
AUDIENCE: Been a while.
NEIL GIBSON: Been a while.
I'm actually going to come
on to that in a minute.
Fantastic.
Good.
OK, well, welcome to talk.
Thanks for being
here, first of all.
This talk is about
how comics can help
your memory and your career.
And I generally believe
that whether you're
studying or working,
comics really can help you.
My objective with this talk is
to give you tools afterwards so
that you actually use
and start using comics,
either to help your memory
or to help your career.
And I'll explain why afterwards.
OK.
So the agenda is,
first of all, it's
the public perception of
comics, because you're
unusual in that most of
you actually read comics.
Most people I speak to don't.
But a lot of people
think comics,
and they immediately
think superheroes
or they think kids' stuff.
And it's unfortunate, but
that is the public perception.
I want to get into why that's
the case, because if you're
going to use comics, especially
in the work environment,
you need to able to counter
the public perception.
The next thing,
I'm going to have
to give you examples of
the advantages comics
have over other mediums.
All mediums have advantages.
For example, music and
radio, you can multitask.
You can do something else at
the same time you're listening.
You can't do that with a
film, because your attention
can't be split like that.
And comics have a
definite advantage
over the other mediums.
Then I'll tell you exactly how
comics can help you and give
examples, And then we'll
do a live demonstration
on how you can make your own
comics, because I can't draw.
So don't worry if
you can't draw.
That's not a problem.
I'll show you how you
can get around that.
And finally, there's questions
and free comics at the end,
if you want them.
So first of all, a
little bit about me.
My name is Neil Gibson.
That's Neil Gibson, not
Mel Gibson, all right?
That's me.
That's not me.
Please, don't confuse us.
Because whenever
I go to countries
where English isn't
the first language,
I often get confused
with Mel Gibson.
And people think it's the
first time I've heard it.
They think it's
hilarious, I don't.
OK.
So how I got into comics.
Well, I got into
really them quite late.
I read them as a
kid, but it was--
well, I grew up.
I stopped reading them
because I felt like I grew up.
But I got back into
comics because of this.
Can anyone tell me who that is?
What was that?
AUDIENCE: Wolverine?
NEIL GIBSON: Absolutely, yeah.
I had just finished university
and was backpacking,
and I was in Vancouver at the
time, and the film "X-Men"
had just come out.
And I had a friend of mine.
We used to joke that he
wanted to be Wolverine,
so I thought I'd buy
that as a joke present.
I went into the shop,
and at that time--
this was back in 2000, all the
top creators, writers of comics
were British.
You had Alan Moore, Neil Gaiman,
Garth Ennis, Warren Ellis,
Grant Morrison.
And when I got talking
to the guys in the shop,
and they assumed I
personally knew these people,
and I had to point out I
hadn't even heard of them.
And then it goes to a
blank look, and they said,
"but you've read
'Watchmen,' right?"
Well, I said, "No."
They said, "Stay here."
And this girl went to
the back of the shop.
And I'll never forget
the way she did this.
She came back and with such
intensity said, "Buy this."
And I did.
And I remember feeling silly
as I walked out the shop.
I thought, "I spent $30 on
something I don't really want."
But I read it, and it
changed my life, really.
I became a massive fan of
comics for the next 12 years.
I read loads of them.
And the reason it
changed my life is I
didn't realize how
intelligent comics could be.
I assumed it was all just
people punching each other
or the "Beano," like kid stuff.
So why did it affect me so much?
I had preconceptions,
and a lot of people
do about comics who
don't read them.
So let's talk about
the first point,
public perception of comics.
And first of all, the difference
between medium and content.
So who here used to
listen to music as a kid?
See, you guys are awesome.
Normally, I do this talk,
and no one raises their hand.
So I make a joke saying
you're all liars or something.
But you guys are actually
very interactive.
I even have bribes here.
I threw sweets to people,
the first hand that goes up.
You guys just all raised them.
So you don't get the sweets.
So the answer is everyone
listened to music as a kid.
And I'm not saying I own that.
I'm not saying I owned that.
I did.
But your tastes change
as you get older,
and normally the content
you consume would change.
It's the same with TV.
Like, I watched "Sesame
Street" as a kid.
I don't anymore.
Your tastes change, but the
medium is still the same.
You still consume
the same medium.
But for comics, well, you
could read it as a kid,
and especially in this
country, it's the "Beano."
And a lot of them just stop.
But they don't need to, because
the content is out there
for people, but more
people just don't find it,
because they see it is
just a limited palette.
A lot of people I recommend
"Sandman" to, for example.
Why do they stop?
Well, a lot of it is
public pressure as well.
I remember when I
first told a friend
of mine reading a manga comic
called "Lone Wolf and Cub."
And I was waiting for
her in a restaurant.
And she said, "You can't read
comics forever, can you?"
And it was a little
bit offensive to me
because she just genuinely
looked down on them.
And so why is it that
people do look down on them?
Well, I apologize to any
Rob Liefeld fans out there,
but I don't blame people for
it if the available content is
awful.
If you're new to comics
and you go into a shop,
or you're trying to
graduate from the "Beano"
and this is what you discover
in the shop, well, I'm sorry.
That's just silly.
I mean look at the
proportions here.
No human looks like that.
It's overly muscly.
The anatomy is completely wrong.
And however bad male characters
are portrayed in comics,
female characters
are usually worse.
That is a human spine.
It's right angles.
It's ridiculous!
So if that's what people--
if that's all they see when
they first go into a comic shop,
I don't blame them
for not trying more.
Another reason is,
historically, it was humorous.
Comics were called comics
because they were comical.
Another word for them
is the funny pages.
And my book there, that
psychological thriller,
"Twisted Dark," I gave it to my
uncle, and he read a bit of it
and said, "Neil, is this
supposed to make me laugh?"
No, it's not, but
people just assume
that comics should be funny.
Another reason they're looked
down upon is poor logic.
So if someone says "all
crows are black," fine.
Oh, this bird is black,
therefore, it must be a crow.
That's not really
good logic, but people
do apply it to comics.
All children's books
tend to have pictures,
because that's how
they learn what
the world is like, what
a castle looks like,
what a rocket looks like.
So all children's
books have pictures.
Oh, this book has pictures.
Therefore it must be
a children's book.
Now, you guys are
all Google employees
who are super smart,
so you'd never
make that kind of mistake,
but a lot of people do.
But I think the main reason in
the English-speaking language
that it's looked
down upon is because
of this guy, Fredric Wertham.
Does anyone here
know who this is?
No.
He wrote a book called
"Seduction of the Innocent,"
in which he wrote
that comic books are
dangerous to children.
And he proved that
children reading comics
were more likely to be
anti-social, more likely
to drink alcohol, to take
drugs, and commit crime.
He was so powerful that
Congress launched an inquiry
into comics.
Across schools in America,
they burned comic books.
it's true.
And what Congress did was they
launched the Comic Book Code,
which meant that comic books
could not be marketed or have
adult or mature themes.
Had to be limited to
people 13 or younger.
So it made the material puerile.
So unlike content
in France or Japan,
where it can have
whatever you want,
until fairly recently, it
had to be limited age-wise.
And when he died--
in his book, he went
on to say that "I
think Hitler was a beginner
compared to the comic book
industry."
That's an incredible
statement to make.
That shows you how
anti-comics he was.
And when he died, it was
proved that he fabricated
everything, made it all up.
But we're still feeling
the effects today.
The good news is that
perceptions do change.
Does anyone know
who this guy is?
No?
OK, well, this is Jack LaLanne.
You see those handcuffs there?
He swam a mile upriver, towing
70 rowboats behind his back.
A mile with 70 rowboats, the
last one full of passengers.
And he did it with his hands
handcuffed behind his back.
And he did it when
he was 70 years old.
One rowboat per
year for his life.
And the reason I
mention all this
is because he is the guy who
invented weights machines.
Gyms as they exist today
wouldn't exist without him.
He was a hero of
Arnold Schwarzenegger.
And when he first started
saying that you should lift out
with weights and use these
machines, doctors at the time
said, working out with weights
will give people heart attacks
and they will lose
their sex drive.
They were vehemently
opposed to him.
But obviously, today,
things have changed.
Now it's a central part
of any athletic training.
Another perception
that's changed
is "Smoking is good for you."
More doctors smoked Camels
than any other cigarette.
And that is a young
Ronald Reagan,
the future president of
America, advertising cigarettes.
Now, that wouldn't happen today.
Another thing that's changed,
"Women have smaller brains.
They aren't as
intelligent as men."
This was a real reason
why women weren't given
the vote, a real reason quoted.
Now, it is true that,
physically, women
do have smaller brains,
but intelligence
is made of gray matter.
Women have a higher
percentage of that,
so it works out the same.
And finally this--
"No black man will ever be
considered for president."
This was said by the
Reverend Jeremiah Wright
three years before
Barack Obama was elected.
And what I find amazing
is that this reverend
was his own reverend.
Anyway, the good news
is that perceptions
do change, and the perceptions
of comics will change,
and with your help,
will happen sooner.
That's the perception of
comics, but what advantage
do they have over other mediums?
Well, let's start with pacing.
For me, comics sit in
between books and film.
The best communication you ever
get, I think, in my experience,
is when you're with someone
you're in complete rapport
with.
You finish each other's
sentences, the way they speak,
their cadence, their
intonation, the way they move,
you're just completely in
sync and you understand
what they're saying 100%.
But that's very
rare, and you tend
to be very similar
to that person
to be able to get
that kind of rapport.
So you don't have
that mass appeal.
But with books, the advantage
of books is you decide the pace.
You can go as fast or
as slow as you like.
You can skip
passages if you want.
You can skim read.
Or you can pore over what the
meanings of these actual words
are.
With films, the director
decides the pace.
You don't get a
choice in the matter.
And that lands you into trouble
sometimes, because, for myself,
for example, I sometimes
speak too quickly for people.
What's worse is people
who speak too slowly.
That just drives me mad.
You don't get a choice
when it gets to films.
It's given to you at the
speed the director chooses.
And sometimes it's too much,
sometimes it's too slow.
Comics, to me, is
wonderfully in the middle,
because, again, like
books, you decide the pace,
but you can be guided
by the pictures.
And it's very efficient,
because a picture
says a thousand words.
They can reduce the amount
of text in the page,
or the size of the panels,
or the detail of the panels
to guide you through it.
With books, you create the
entire character's surroundings
in the world.
If you want to lose yourself
for a couple of hours,
a great way to do that is to
play video games, to program,
or to read a book.
With a film, you see and
hear all the characters
but are limited
by the direction.
And again, with comics, you
get to see the body language
of someone, what someone's
feeling in their body in how
they move and how they--
but the transition
between the panels
and how the characters sound,
what they're really like,
is, again, in your head.
All of these, your
interpretation
can be very personal, because
they're all great mediums.
But another way of saying
this is that no medium
is superior to the other.
They all have their own
advantages and disadvantages.
For me, one of the main
advantages of comics
is the pacing.
Next is ease of vision.
I've got a question
for you guys.
First right question
gets a packet of sweets.
So what percentage of
neurons in the brain cortex
do you think is
devoted to hearing?
AUDIENCE: 20%.
NEIL GIBSON: 20%.
Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: 10.
NEIL GIBSON: 10?
One more.
5?
We're getting closer.
It's only 3%.
What about touch?
AUDIENCE: 5%.
NEIL GIBSON: 5%?
AUDIENCE: 1%.
NEIL GIBSON: 1%?
No, it's 8%.
What about vision?
AUDIENCE: 30%.
NEIL GIBSON: There you go.
Well done.
It is 30%.
That's 10 times as
many as hearing.
Vision dominates
the other senses.
Even your retina itself is
an outcrop of the brain.
It's the only part of the brain
that's not inside the cortex.
So what?
Why does that matter?
Well, vision is so easy, it's
so quick to understand things.
I'm going to show you
now four pictures,
and in a fraction
of a second, you're
going to get two or three
meanings from each picture
without any effort.
You ready?
All right, done.
Instantly all of you saw that
this is a toothbrush holder.
That's a cloud.
That's a bag.
That's a sink.
You also saw that's a
smiley face on these three.
Maybe that's a Shopped one.
And that's a human body.
And if you want a bit more
detail, this is joyous.
This one looks almost smug.
And that one looks shocked.
And that is not a euphoric
movement of that character,
as it were, because
it's like it's stressed.
It's under tension.
Something's going on there.
You can get those
meanings from it
so quickly without any effort.
And that's what I love
about how easy comics are--
your understanding.
You can instantly make
sense of pictures.
And to give you another
example of this,
I'm going to show you
just this panel here.
Special bonus points
if anyone can tell me
what comic this is from.
But can someone tell me what
is going on in this panel?
What do they see happening?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NEIL GIBSON: Fantastic, yeah.
Perhaps that's a
padded room over there.
Wherever they are, you can
tell it's been there a while.
There's cracks in the wall.
It's not a new location.
To me, perhaps this is a
security guard by this cable
here.
What's interesting
to me is, I don't
know if this is male or female.
It's androgynous and
hair that's distinctive.
To have the strength to break
someone's neck like that
is extraordinary, but
it's not very muscly.
There's Something unusual there.
And this person seems totally
uninterested in this as well.
There's no emotion on the face.
And even these three
lines here implies hat
this person is
distracted elsewhere.
The girl is almost an
afterthought to this character.
Even her dialogue is cut off.
And the artist has changed
the angle of the panel
to make it look more intense.
This is all stuff--
I don't even know what's
actually happening in there.
This is what you can
pick up from the picture.
And the reason I
mention all this
is because a picture's
a thousand words.
Communication through pictures
is incredibly efficient.
If you choose the
time to look at it,
because you can spend as much
time on this as you want,
you can just look at it, go,
"oh, it's killed someone,"
and you move on
to the next panel.
It's your choice.
Another advantage, though,
apart from the ease of vision,
is memory retention.
And this is where it gets
very interesting to me.
Have you ever been
reading a book
and you put it down for a day
or two, and you come back,
and you you've lost
your page in the book?
And you wonder,
where am I in this?
And you flick through--
have I read this
before, this bit or not?
Yeah, some people.
Yeah.
What's more common,
you're actually
reading a page of text, and
suddenly you realize, oh, I
haven't taken any of this in.
And you have to go
back and reread it.
Everyone's experienced
that, right?
With comics, both of these
happen a lot less frequency.
First of all, for
the picture, it's
because visual recall is
so much higher for images
than it is for text.
And they do studies--
they've done studies on
babies and monkeys, babies
with images of people.
And if they keep showing
new people, new faces--
and it can be same
with lemurs as well--
humans can't really distinguish
between different lemurs, even
humans who have worked with
them their entire lives.
So a baby, way the
brain works, if it's
a different image,
a different picture,
it'll hold their attention.
Show the same one twice,
and they'll look away.
They've lost interest.
Whereas with monkeys,
they've done experiments
with the lever, and
they'll show photographs.
If they've seen the
photograph before
and they mark it as seen,
they get a banana pellet.
If they haven't seen it before,
they'll mark the other way.
And monkeys show
incredible memory retention
for visual images.
They can show them the
picture once three months ago,
and they'll remember
they've seen it.
As for not taking in a page,
again, your comprehension
is usually much
higher with comics
than it is with just text.
You don't normally go
back and say, well, I
haven't taken this
in, because you
understand from the
pictures what's happening.
Now, I do say "usually"
here, because just like there
are some awful books,
there are some awful TV,
there's some awful
music out there,
there are some awful comics.
Right?
I do love the medium,
but it doesn't
mean I love all the content.
Now, combining the
recall aspect of this,
that you can remember
it, and the comprehension
gives you an advantage.
And in neurology, this is
called the pictorial superiority
effect.
And Alex Lundry has done some
extensive research on this.
If you present
information orally,
like if I gave you
this talk without any
of these pictures, just hearing
it as opposed to seeing it,
72 hours after you hear
something, typically recall is,
according to Alex Lundry,
10% if you just hear it.
Whereas if you add pictures,
recall soars to 65%.
Now, that to me
is extraordinary.
Over six times as effective
recall when you add pictures
to what you're saying.
We are hard-wired to
find visualization more
compelling than a spreadsheet.
So look at this data here,
and please tell me which
product or region is different.
Region 3, absolutely.
Showing this, here
you can clearly
see that these have all gone
up but [? T ?] has gone down,
whereas if you do this
graphically, red's gone up.
The other two are trending down.
Now, it shouldn't be news to
you that understanding this
is easier than this, right?
Now, there's science
behind why it's the case,
but that's intuitive.
What's interesting
is that if you're
trying to make a point
in the presentation,
not only is this
easier to understand,
but people will remember
it more afterwards.
And that's why you're giving
the talk in the first place,
because you want it
to make a difference.
So how can comics
actually help you?
And I've gone
through and explained
the advantages of the medium.
Well, I used to work as
a management consultant.
And I was on a project
in [? Amman ?] once.
And this company was
building roads and bridges,
and they had a
problem, because they
had a production department
and a maintenance department.
And the production
department, their job
was to build, build,
build as fast as possible.
They had deadlines to meet.
Whereas the maintenance
department's job
was to keep the equipment
maintained properly
and avoid downtime.
But they were experiencing
huge levels of downtime
because the production guys
wouldn't release the equipment
for maintenance,
because they wanted
to meet their targets, which
resulted in when it did
fail, failing
catastrophically, and having
to do expensive
rebuilds and have
expensive hiring for
emergency equipment.
So the cheap solution
was to use a comic.
"It's time for preventive
maintenance on the equipment."
"No time.
We have to work."
"It'll just take three hours."
"Nope, sorry."
"At least let us grease it."
"No time."
And of course it breaks.
"How much time to repair it?"
"Oh, not long.
Just three weeks."
Now, this is very
simple, this comic.
But what they did was they
took this and they blew it up,
and they put it in all
the regional offices,
and they put small
versions of this
and stuck this inside each
machine, inside each crane,
inside each truck,
inside each bulldozer.
So whenever someone didn't want
to release it for equipment,
the maintenance guys just go
in and point to the picture.
And a lot of these guys
didn't speak or read English,
but they knew what
the comic was.
And this resulted in a big
reduction in their downtime.
My question to you is why?
Why did this work?
It's because it was
easy to understand.
There was no effort
required for these people,
and it was there, right in
front of them, the whole time.
Or it can be more professional.
This was a comic we made
for a company called Komodo.
They were the first
company to guarantee
against virus infections.
So if your company got
viruses on your computers,
they'd give you like
100,000 pounds or something.
And their problem was
the IT departments
of their customers
wanted to buy it,
but the management
wouldn't sign off.
So we made this comic telling
a story of a virus infecting
a company and escalating.
Eventually,
everyone's going nuts
because they
couldn't do any work
and trying to guilt
management to realizing
that it was their fault,
because they didn't
take the preventive measures.
And what we did here
was we also put--
this was the sales
guy at conventions.
He'd give these leaflets
out to all these IT
guys who didn't just give
this to the management guys,
but they'd remember
who they spoke to.
Because I don't
know about you guys,
but I've been to many
networking events,
and you get so many
business cards.
And you look at
like a month later,
and you go, who is this person?
You don't remember.
You actually see what
the guy looks like.
You remember it.
So compared to the
other competitors,
who are they more
likely to go for?
Someone they know and recognize.
We also made one
for an oil company.
They had a warehouse system they
were implementing worldwide.
And so we taught people
about the system,
how it worked, and made it funny
with the president and vice
president looking
like the people.
I had them arguing
with each other.
And yes, the recall and
retention was why we did it,
but why they liked it so much
was not what we expected.
It's because they tried several
new initiatives in the past,
and no one would read them.
Everyone's so busy, they don't--
I can get to that later.
It's not for me.
With that warehouse
comic, it was funny.
Even people who had nothing
to do with the warehouse
had read it, because it
is different and fun.
OK.
OK, Neil, calm down.
I get that comics can
be effective at work.
What about study?
What about for memory?
Well, in Japan, they
teach GSCE-level physics
using comic books,
even up to engineering.
In India, in Bangalore,
there's a medical school
which is teaching
medicine through comics.
Even some of our
comic, "Twisted Dark,"
is used in schools in
the US, UK, and Canada
to teach about social issues.
The University of Chicago
even uses one of the stories
to teach about
modern-day slavery.
And they do it because it's
more compelling as a story,
and it's different.
It shakes people up, as opposed
to the normal, dry textbooks.
If you ever get confused
just once, draw a picture.
That's the red sun setting with
the blue sea in front of you.
None of you will ever get this
wrong the rest of your lives
now that you've seen this.
If you think about
redshift, blueshift,
you'll remember that, oh the
sun's setting on the sea.
I guarantee you you'll
never get that wrong.
And you can do this
in groups with people.
And we did this at school.
Actually, someone else
did something different.
They took a firetruck and the
fireman firing the blue water
towards them.
Whatever comes to
your mind first.
But drawing these pictures,
as when you have a physics
problem, you're always
taught to draw a diagram
to help you visualize
it and remember it.
So this is a very effective tool
for exams to remember things.
OK, OK, I get it, Neil.
But I need to convince others.
OK.
Well, first of all, if you're
going to use this stuff,
comics are fun.
OK?
They're not intimidating.
It's not like seeing
a big block of text.
They're friendly.
Memory retention is higher.
They're quick to read.
You can learn more faster.
And they're more likely to
be shared and passed around.
Let's park those
points for a minute
and then go into Kirkpatrick's
model of sequential learning.
And this model, I
like to go backwards.
As I said before, whenever
you teach anyone anything,
you want results.
You want to make a
difference, what you taught.
It's only going make
a difference if they
use what you taught them.
They're only going to
use what you taught them
if they've learned it.
And they're much more
likely to learn it
if they liked or
saw a use for it.
Did they like it?
Well, comics are fun, and
they're not intimidating.
Did they learn it?
Well, memory
retention is higher,
and they're quick to read.
You can learn more, faster.
You can read the thing faster.
And did they use it?
They're more likely to
be shared with others.
And when lots of people do
something, the culture changes.
And here's some more ammunition.
This was just last month.
Psychologists at Sheffield
Hallam University
investigated how well
students learn something.
And they went through
three different methods.
It was comics, the
traditional text, and text
with incongruous images.
And I think it
was for neurology.
It was standard
coursework, but they just
put it in this format.
And this was the comic
they actually used.
And what they found
was comics by far
were the best method
for teaching for people
to remember the core concepts.
And they did multiple
choice questions afterwards.
But what's interesting is that
text with the wrong images
came last.
You have to know
what you're doing.
You have to have--
it's showing, not telling, but
showing the right thing so it
makes sense with the text.
And the actual
quote they said was,
"Combining relevant
images and text
creates the maximum memorability
for educational material."
This is edutainment.
They're even being used in
South Africa for people who
can't read as legal documents.
Have you heard about this?
AUDIENCE: No.
NEIL GIBSON: OK.
This is a fruit-picking company,
and you have a three-week trial
period, picking fruit.
This is the amount
you need to pick.
If you don't make it, sorry.
You're sad.
You go home.
If you make it,
the trial is over.
Welcome to the team.
Sign there.
Legal document.
Examples for professional use--
NASA uses it to explain
about ionosphere.
Yahoo mapped how they
inferface [? engineering ?]
in comic books.
Kelmer Investment Company
taught about options
using comic books.
Even you guys, Google,
launched the Chrome
using Scott McCloud's comic.
I read that entire comic
because it was a comic book
all about Chrome.
User manuals, I don't
normally read them.
I normally just go and play
with them, but I read that one.
But this one is the
biggest one for me.
The 9/11 Commission, they made
a book about the findings.
Why?
Because no one read
the original one.
It was so big and so dry
and dull, no one read it.
So two graphic novelists
went and made it
in the graphic format, and
then half of Congress read it.
It's all about the result you
want, and because they read it,
they're more likely to remember
what they actually read.
Great.
So now hopefully
I've convinced you
that there is merit in this.
But how do you make
your own comics?
Because when I draw,
there's not much difference
between seven-year-old me
drawing and my age now drawing.
So you don't need
to be able to draw.
I mean, you could even do
like XKCD or something,
stick insects, stick
men drawing things.
You can do things that way.
But if you want to
make it look nicer,
there's a free app
called Prisma, which
you can download on your phone.
And I checked this morning.
Comic Life is another
app you might need,
which costs just 4.99.
So all you do is
you take photographs
of the scene on your phone,
plug it into prism, the photos,
and select a filter
you want to use.
It will take a couple of
seconds to process it,
and then it changes
into a comic book font.
It's got a comic
book feel to it.
To show you some examples,
I tried a few of them.
And I did that did this just
a few days ago with some guys
around the office.
Try this way, this one, this
one, which I did not like,
and that one.
So I decided to make a comic
using this particular filter,
which I'll take you to.
OK, so this is Comic Life.
OK.
And these are the pictures
we have right here.
All you need to do is, after
you have these pictures,
you can just take
them and drop them in.
Done.
And you can move them
around if you want,
but I think this
frames up perfectly
for this particular panel.
Then you take the
next one, pop it in.
And let's say I want to take
this one and put this in here.
I actually want to--
I can't fit both of
them in this panel.
I can change the
size of these panels
if I wanted by dragging
things different sizes.
Here, I want to zoom in on
this guy's angry expression.
And that's going to go there.
And then to add
the balloons, you
can drag these things
up here and say--
hang on a bit.
Put it up here.
Put this tail down here.
Or add captions.
"Dan was a good worker."
OK.
Look how quickly
I'm making this.
It's so easy.
So here's one I made earlier.
And the reason this came
about, actually, was because--
before I show you
this, these guys,
they're doing a
documentary with us,
and they are saying
that they hate meetings
where people are always
playing with their phone
or answering them.
Well, I needed some
demonstration for today,
so I thought we'd make this.
So "Dan was a good worker
except in meetings.
Hang on.
Again?
He was always on his phone.
Now he's texting?
Didn't realize how
much he upset people.
Well, he soon found out.
No phones in meetings, unless
you want to end up like Dan."
That was just something we
threw together quickly, right?
But you can see--
I can tell right now by
the smiles on your faces,
if you put up a poster saying
"no phones in meetings,"
how effective is that?
How engaging is
that with people,
as opposed something like this?
And it's all about
the result you want.
Now, maybe phones
in the meetings
aren't a big problem
for you, but actually it
is for a lot of companies.
But if there's an important
message you want to get across,
is it worth spending--
and this whole thing
took me about 15 minutes,
most of it processing power
for Prisma.
15 minutes to the whole thing.
If you want to get an
important message across,
is it worth spending 15
minutes doing something
that will engage people and
that they will remember?
I think it is.
So I'm just going back
to the presentation.
And it's not just for studying
and for memory or for work.
This is something we did
with a charity called
Check One Two because it was
in conjunction with Stephen Fry
and [? Anton Deck. ?] It's
about testicular cancer.
Breast cancer has had
massive reductions
in this country due to proper
screening and awareness,
but testicular cancer has
stayed pretty much level.
Men don't check themselves.
So we made a comic
which was actually aimed
at women to show men in
their lives, made it funny,
having a little feel
there, testing himself.
And this was just to get
people to check themselves.
I think it's a
worthwhile message,
and apparently it was effective.
They used it in their campaign.
So going back to why people
stopped reading comics
at the end-- this is just
a parting message on this.
People do stop
reading comics mostly
because they don't evolve
the content they're taking.
But there is so much
content out there
which will suit
almost anyone's taste.
I genuinely believe that.
And you can read it
for many reasons.
You can read it just
because you like stories,
or because you like
fantasy stories,
or you like superhero stories.
Whatever you like.
But let's say you like
historical comics.
A lot of people ask me
if I could recommend one
for comic for them,
what shall I recommend?
My honest answer is, well,
if you're reading it just
for fun and
enjoyment of reading,
what content do you enjoy
film-wise or book-wise?
So if someone says
they like history,
well, I recommend "Maus."
Anyone read this?
Two people, three people.
Good.
So this is a fantastic comic.
This is the first comic
to win a Pulitzer Prize.
And this is set in the
'80s and in the run-up
to the Second World War.
And it's about this
guy who doesn't really
get on with his father.
He's a horrible man, but he
has incredible respect for him
because he survived Auschwitz.
And it makes you laugh,
and it makes you cry,
and it educates you so much
of what actually happened.
It's fascinating.
Or let's say you want
to learn something.
I studied engineering
at university,
and my roommate studied physics.
And he had this book called
"Introducing Einstein," which,
because I read that, I know
the theory of relativity
and I can explain it anyone,
which I think is fantastic.
I doubt I would have gone and
picked up a textbook to read
about the theory of relativity.
But because it was in comic book
format and funny and well told,
I definitely did.
On the back of this,
though, as a warning,
I read "Introducing
Chaos Theory,"
and that was terribly written.
I don't understand any of that.
So if someone could explain that
to me later, that'd be great.
Or about travel.
If someone likes
travel, this is a guy
who spent time in North Korea.
And just how bizarre
the life style is there.
Every public room
has photographs
with frames at an angle, so
it's looking down at you,
of the family.
Or you can learn
about the economy
or the Arab-Israeli Conflict.
Or even if you're not
reading it for fun
but for social interactions,
I have a Japanese friend.
And this is amazing to me.
I didn't even know this.
She read a bunch of manga
when she moved to the UK
on Shakespeare and classic
English literature,
like "Pride and Prejudice,"
so that in dinner parties
or in casual
conversation she could
have a meaningful discussion
about these things
without having to spend the time
of reading all these classics.
Now, if they're
great classics, you
might want to read
them yourselves
for the enjoyment of it,
but if you're doing it
for a different objective,
whatever your end result is,
that's a great way of doing it.
Again, because
it's quick to read,
and you'll remember
it for conversations.
So I think this
is my final slide.
Are there any bad examples
of companies using comics?
Yes, and I think
the biggest culprit
worldwide has to be IKEA.
This is awful.
I mean, even the
structure of it.
Books are the shape
they are for a reason.
Over thousands of years,
there's science behind that
as well, why humans
like that shape.
You have to go all the
way across here before you
find the first panel.
If someone reads a
comic and people say,
"oh, I don't know which
panels to read next,"
that means the creators
have failed you.
Because it should be easy,
the way the flow is done.
They've had to put
numbers in this.
And the journeys one will read
through this is there to there,
to there, then it goes all
way over there, then down up.
It's terrible.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] pay
someone to do it for you.
NEIL GIBSON: Well, my
feedback on this is,
actually, has anyone ever
actually made something
from IKEA and made a mistake?
Yeah, you've never
made a mistake?
Not once?
AUDIENCE: I plan it out.
NEIL GIBSON: Classic
Google employee here.
Well done, sir.
Well done.
AUDIENCE: I get my
pencil and mark it.
[INAUDIBLE]
NEIL GIBSON: OK, that's great.
I have a master's
in engineering,
and I've made mistakes.
OK?
I think these are terrible
instructions, if I'm honest.
And I don't think
anyone's made a mistake as
bad as this woman, who's on the
floor in shame after what she
did.
I mean, that was
truly unforgivable.
But if they gave
this to people who
knew what they're doing
comic book people,
they can make this so
much more engaging,
and people wouldn't
make as many mistakes.
And yes, IKEA do print this
on very thin, cheap paper,
and they do it in as
few panels as possible,
but I think adding an extra
two or three pages to this
would make the experience so
much better for customers.
They wouldn't have the dread
of having to assemble it
or having to pay
other people about it.
And they also maybe
even have a competition
on Twitter about it, like
how was your experience?
How many mistakes did you make?
Turn it into a positive thing.
If I was in IKEA, I'd definitely
be getting proper people
to do this.
And I actually think
in IKEA job interviews,
they might want to
do this, and have
their manual versus a
comic manual, someone
who knows what they're doing.
So in this talk, I've explain to
you about the public perception
of comics, the advantages
of the medium, how
it can be useful for you,
how to make your own comics.
And I would really
love, if any of you
have any questions after this,
to get in contact with me,
because I want you guys
to use comics in some way.
It could be helping
your children revise.
It could be helping change the
culture of a different company.
It could be a
significant problem
that people are having
that you want to change
or a marketing idea.
Whatever it is,
I'd love to help,
because I genuinely care about
the medium, and I think--
actually, I know that if you
do use comments correctly,
they really can help you, either
in your studies or your career.
Hope you found it interesting.
Thank for listening to me.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Thank you very much.
We do have time for questions.
AUDIENCE: I just saw you
have described how anybody
can draw using the images.
Is that how you
have made this book?
I mean, do you do
photo shoot-outs
with actors or
something like that?
How do you make a
big story out of it?
NEIL GIBSON: I personally don't.
That was just a quick
way of doing it,
because when people
buy comics, they
buy it for one of four reasons.
And everyone has
their own preferences,
but generally
speaking, the majority
buy it for actually the
stories, then for the art,
then for the coloring,
and some people
buy just for the lettering,
if you can believe it.
So a large market is
because of the artwork.
So all the work we
do, it constantly
gets better and better.
So doing it using photos
is a cheat for some people,
because they want
to actually see art.
So that's why we don't.
AUDIENCE: But you actually draw?
NEIL GIBSON: Me?
No, that requires talent.
So no, I don't.
No, I have a team of
artists I work with.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So one medium which
lots of people
have got onto now with
all the forums and reddits
and everything is memes.
So that's kind of an
accessible comic creation.
NEIL GIBSON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So what's
your thoughts on those?
NEIL GIBSON: Comics are
actually sequential artwork,
so it has to be time-based.
Memes tend to be just one
picture, so that, to me,
is a cartoon rather
than a comic.
That's getting a bit analytical
about it, academic about it.
But I think memes are great.
Some of them are hilarious.
Some of them are stupid.
Some of them I don't
understand, frankly.
But they can be very
effective, and the reason
they are so popular
now is because people
share them, because it speaks
to them, it gets a reaction.
So the good ones are great.
The bad ones, well, are
not shared for a reason.
Is that a fair enough answer?
Oh, by the way,
the best question
gets a copy of my
brand-new book.
This won't be available in
stores till I think next year.
So the best question gets this.
That's an incentive for you.
AUDIENCE: That's
a lot of pressure.
Yeah, I wanted to
ask if you have used
a comic for your personal use?
Not for careers or drawing
a comic for other companies.
Have you created your own
comic for your personal use,
like to educate your
kids or whatever?
NEIL GIBSON: I did,
and it backfired on me.
So I made this.
This is cool "World
of Chub Chub."
And this is true
stories of me as a kid.
I mean, these are
stories my mum used
to like telling everyone of what
I did, of what a bad kid I was,
and how funny it was.
It's funny now.
It wasn't funny at the time.
So I made this comic as a
gift to her for her birthday,
and she found it so
funny she shared it
with her friends, which
was not my intention.
And then they all said, "Neil,
you have to publish this."
"No, this is private.
This is--" But no, they made me.
She made me do it.
So now everyone knows
what a bad kid I was.
So I did it for my own
personal reasons, yes, but ah,
I did it for
educational purposes--
So for educational purposes,
I did it as well for one guy.
Because he had
difficulty understanding
the difference between
"affect" and "effect," right?
And he was a writer.
So I drew an image
of special effects,
and the special effects
blew out in a big E shape.
OK.
And there was someone
else who went "Ah!"
He was hit by it, and
he was shouting "Ah."
And his body shape
was like an A.
The special effects affect him.
So that way, he's not
going to forget it.
AUDIENCE: Was it effective?
NEIL GIBSON: It was
effective, not affective, yes.
Question?
Anyone else?
Sorry, I thought-- no, sorry.
SPEAKER: Questions, questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What comics
do you personally
enjoy reading for fun?
NEIL GIBSON: I read
a lot of comics.
I have a massive
library at home.
Unfortunately, the comic
book world isn't that big.
So I read all the
great stuff, I think.
So my current
favorite right now is
"Saga," which is the
biggest-selling comic
in the world right now.
It used to be "The
Walking Dead,"
because it's overtaken them.
But other than that, I'm
struggling to find good stuff.
[INAUDIBLE] more
independent creators
who aren't that professional,
but I meet them at comic cons
and I buy their stuff.
But if you have any
recommendations afterwards,
I would love to hear
them, because I'm always
looking for good content.
AUDIENCE: Have
you had any issues
with expressing something
that is somewhat
like an abstract concept
in a way through comics?
Like, for example,
there was the concept--
there was the comic
about Einstein's--
wouldn't that take some of the
value away that a wall of text
would have in expressing
abstract concepts more easily?
NEIL GIBSON: Ah, that's
a very good point.
I've never had to--
I've never personally had to
make very abstract concepts,
because most of the stuff I
write or publish is fiction.
Or it's very clear, the
message you want to get across.
When it's something
very complic--
Like, I've always thought
advanced mathematics
and theoretical physicists
are the smartest
people on the planet, because
the way their brains work,
these concepts which--
I get that.
Oh, wait.
No, I don't get it anymore.
It's very difficult to
wrap your head around.
I have not had to do it
myself, so "I don't know"
is the answer for that.
But I still think just from
when I was studying engineering,
they bring in models
for you to look at,
and rather than
just reading text,
showing images always
is more effective.
I still remember those
models years later.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but
I guess the problem
is how to show them
so that you express
more abstract concepts in a
way that is visually memorable.
NEIL GIBSON: I
think you're going
to have to give me an
example of something.
AUDIENCE: Like if
you teach programming
to someone for instance.
NEIL GIBSON: Programming?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
NEIL GIBSON: OK.
AUDIENCE: I don't see a way of
expressing that through comics
without having a wall of
text in one of the comics,
or just having
text with examples.
NEIL GIBSON: Oh, I
see what you mean.
OK, fine.
Yes, fine.
Well, for programming,
you'd have
to have the text, because that's
what you're actually doing.
But I'll tell you what.
If you actually want
to discuss this,
I can talk to you
afterwards, and we can
go through a practical example.
I'll see if I can actually help
you on that, because I actually
would love to see if I could.
AUDIENCE: Have you seen Scratch?
NEIL GIBSON: Nope.
AUDIENCE: Scratch is a kind
of a graphical programming
environment.
NEIL GIBSON: Ah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but
that's different.
I was just thinking
if we could express
textbook sort of
subjects into comics
and whether this would be
a limitation of comics.
NEIL GIBSON: I don't know.
I'll talk to you afterward
about it, but what I will say
is I remember when I was
young, science textbooks, they
were very text-heavy and didn't
have many pictures, compared
to by the time I got to just
before I started university,
they were so much more
glossy with color,
and they had a lot, maybe
five times as many diagrams
as the ones that were
around when I was a kid,
because they're effective.
So I do think there
probably is a way,
but I have to go into
the specifics of how
to actually help you on this.
I have to discuss afterwards.
So no one fault me, OK?
Good, OK.
AUDIENCE: This is more
of a follow-up to that.
So there are some comic
book textbooks that exist.
So for example, "The
Manga Guide to Databases."
There is a lot of text in it,
but giving it reasons to exist.
Like, why do you care
about normalization?
Well, you care about it
because otherwise you
might be giving apples
to the Fairy Kingdom,
and you shouldn't be doing that.
So that can be helpful.
And also you can
better express--
so there's a book.
It's not a comic book.
It's a regular book
book called "If I Only
Changed the Software, Why
is the Phone on Fire?"
which is useful for teaching
process-related bits of coding,
for example, that are
quite difficult to describe
in a traditional
textbook format.
So thought processes, how
stuff happens, and this
is done with a
cast of characters
as a kind of mystery
novel type thing.
So.
NEIL GIBSON: Cool.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What do you think
of digital comics or comics
in a digital form?
NEIL GIBSON: OK, so
that's a good question.
I think you're the contender
for this one right now.
I personally get enough--
like you guys, probably
get enough screen time.
So I personally prefer reading.
I like touching the books
and reading it and flicking
through.
I like having a library where
I can see everything I've read.
So I personally prefer print
massively to digital ones.
However, I'm old, OK?
Young people like
reading digital comics,
and that is the future.
Because with digital comics,
you can reach a mass market.
You can get anyone in
the world instant access
to your material, and you
can share it so much easier.
The thing with digital
comics, though, as well,
is what's interesting to
me is that right now people
will go into Waterstones
or Barnes & Noble,
look at the books they want to
buy, and then on their phone
buy it on Kindle as they're
walking out the shop.
Digital sales of books
exceed print sales of books
and they cannibalize it.
That doesn't happen in comics.
In comics, digital sales
increase print sales
because people want to have
the physical copy as well.
So I think that's great.
I don't think comics are
going to go anywhere.
The consumption does change.
It used to be all
floppies, but now it's
all moved to trade paperbacks.
This is the big growth
area, because people
like having a proper book.
But digital comics
have their place.
A lot of people love them.
I personally like a book.
AUDIENCE: Just as a
follow-on to that,
I almost exclusively read
digital comics, the reason
being, if I have a
comic book in my hand,
I will want to read
the entire thing.
And comic books
these days are too
long to read the entire thing,
and it feels really jarring.
I do the same with
actual novels as well.
But episodic digital
comics are beneficial,
because there's only
one new page every week.
So you're limited in how
much you can binge read.
NEIL GIBSON: I
like binge reading.
I like binge watching Netflix.
AUDIENCE: I do too, but I can't.
NEIL GIBSON: That's
a fair enough point.
Look, it's how you
want to consume it.
That's all your choice.
I personally do think
that when you binge read,
you get more of the
creator's vision for it,
because the story continues.
You don't forget things as much.
I'm quite looking forward
to "Game of Thrones"
when it comes out
later this year,
but I am probably going to
go back and try and find
an online catch-up
in an hour where
I can go through everything
that's happened in the past.
Whereas, so if you're
reading it in one go,
you don't need to do that.
You can read it once.
But it's individual taste.
AUDIENCE: So I guess
a different form
of digital comics, do you
have any experience with--
particularly for the
industrial applications--
interactive comics?
NEIL GIBSON: Yes, I
have experienced them.
I don't like them.
Now, I think there's a
reason it hasn't taken off.
It could be that there hasn't
been enough good enough
content, but I think if
it's like a web comic, where
it's just one button,
so you have the image
and then you click the button
and something extra happens
just there, that is interactive,
and that has its place.
But it hasn't taken
off in the mainstream,
because it's not really a comic.
It's sort of a hybrid.
And maybe there's some
great stuff out there,
but I've yet to see
one where I go, wow,
I really enjoyed this, whereas
there are dozens of comics
which I recommend to people and
say, look, this is fantastic.
I know you will enjoy it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
NEIL GIBSON: It's
my nemesis here.
AUDIENCE: So just a thought
it's on industry comics.
They're really good for
getting across a concept,
getting people to
read the new concept,
and getting information out.
NEIL GIBSON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: But they're
really bad for reference.
So you always need
the text counterpart
to be able to look things up,
because you can't look things
up inside a visual novel.
NEIL GIBSON: What do you
mean "look things up?"
AUDIENCE: So something
has happened.
You need to instantly
reference what
to do to fix that situation.
Basically, an index.
How do you index
into a visual novel,
where the information
could be anywhere
on a page, anywhere in a book?
NEIL GIBSON: Can you
give me an example?
AUDIENCE: For instance, say one
of the databases is blurring up
and there's an error.
How do I find this in my
graphical novel information
about how to fix errors?
NEIL GIBSON: Right.
Well, to me, then
that's a process flow.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
NEIL GIBSON: So you
see the flowchart.
You don't need a
graphic novel for that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
NEIL GIBSON: Graphic novels
are for telling a story.
You knew that when you
asked the question.
AUDIENCE: I'm just saying--
NEIL GIBSON: You're my nemesis.
I was going to give you
this comic, but not anymore.
SPEAKER: I think
we can close here,
so please join me in
thanking Neil Gibson.
NEIL GIBSON: Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]